zdf heute live einen schönen guten abend
und ganz herzlich willkommen ja die
omikron welle ist da schon seit geraumer
zeit wir sind mittendrin und die
infektionszahlen steigen aber das ist
das erfreuliche die lage auf den
intensivstationen die ist relativ stabil
und deshalb gibt es forderungen über
lockerungen was die korona maßnahmen
angeht zumindest jetzt schon
nachzudenken und die frage ist kommen
diese lockerungen diese überlegungen
dazu verführt oder ist das jetzt schon
der richtige zeitpunkt ja zum beispiel
der einzelhandel aber auch der
veranstaltungsbereich der möchte
natürlich gerne entlastet werden darüber
diskutieren wir über diese frage gerne
mit euch fragen und kommentare wie immer
an die gewohnten kanäle und über diese
und wir sprechen darüber mit unseren
beiden gästen die ich jetzt vorstellen
nämlich zum einen mit kirsten kappert
gonther sie ist medizinerin und
bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen
außerdem stellvertretende vorsitzende
und damit aktuelle leiterin des
gesundheitsausschusses im bundestag
herzlich willkommen hallo guten abend
herr wärme und wir sprechen mit klaus
holetschek von der csu dem
gesundheitsminister von bayern einen
schönen guten abend auch ihnen
guten abend und kurz kommt
ihr ministerpräsident mappus so der ert
formuliert man müsse bei der omicron
wand auch nach einer tür suchen durch
die man dann in eine neue zeit gehen
können haben sie dann schon eine ahnung
wo sozusagen die türklinke sein könnte
um da mal im bild zu bleiben
ja ich denke der ministerpräsident hat
richtig formuliert dass wir natürlich
auch jetzt im zwei-wochen-rhythmus zb
auch mal perspektiven aufmachen müssen
ich glaube das erwarten die menschen
auch von uns dass wir jetzt vorsichtig
sind aber trotzdem auch zeigen wie
können wir denn eigentlich weitermachen
planbarkeit auch für den ein oder
anderen zu schaffen das ist glaube ich
jetzt auch der maßstab unter omikron und
das sollten wir auch gemeinsam tun frau
katar konnte wie sind sie denn bereit
oder sind sie überhaupt schon bereit
nach wegen durch die uni konvent zu
suchen oder wie stehen sie aktuell
diesem thema gegenüber also wege suchen
ist immer gut nur aktuell ist überhaupt
nicht der zeitpunkt für lockerungen wir
sind noch mitten in der mikrowelle
wahrscheinlich liegt der peak noch
deutlich vor uns wir wissen nicht ob er
in zwei wochen sein wird oder sogar noch
etwas später im jahr das heißt aktuell
ist für lockerungen überhaupt nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt sondern wir müssen
jetzt kurs halten und die
hygienemaßnahmen die abstandsregeln die
2g plus regeln auch wirklich
flächendeckend durchhalten ja wunderbar
da sind wir schon mittendrin in der
debatte das waren sozusagen die eingangs
statement wir sprechen gleich weiter
wollen uns gerne nochmal so den
allgemeinen blicke auf die diskussion
und den aktuellen stand in dieser holen
und meine kollegin michael vollath viola
übernimmt das
trotz hoher kroner zahlen ist die lage
in den kliniken stabil die sieben tage
incidents steigt neuer höchstwert heute
1000 176,8 die verläufe mit omikron sind
weniger schwer aber zu viele patienten
könnten die krankenhäuser schnell an die
belastungsgrenze bringen und es drohen
personalausfälle trotzdem wird über
lockerungen der korona maßnahmen
diskutiert bremen hat nach berlin und
hamburg die dritthöchste incidents mit
über 1.500
gleichzeitig aber auch die höchste
impfquote mit 86,7 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung
bürgermeister bovenschulte gibt sich
offen für lockerungen ich glaube man
muss sich die entwicklung sehr genau
angucken und jahren kann man und muss
man auch über bestimmte öffnungen
nachdenken insbesondere wenn die
situation auf den intensivstationen so
stabil bleibt und wenn sich bei den
normal betten zeigt dass er ganz
wesentlich auch menschen mit corona und
nicht wegen koma liegen
auch wenn der csu aus bayern kommen
forderungen nach lockerungen dort liegt
die sieben tage incidents bei
überdurchschnittlichen 1000 384,6 nur 72
9 prozent sind zweimal geimpft
zur diskussion stehen bundesweit
besonders die 2g regierung im
einzelhandel und die zuschauerzahlen bei
sport und kulturveranstaltungen die
nächste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist
allerdings erst für mitte februar
angesetzt
genau für den 16 wenn ich das gerade
nochmal nach checke also mitte februar
die nächste genau 16 februar die nächste
konferenz
frau kaputt gonther sie selbst kommen
aus bremen jetzt haben wir gerade dort
den bürgermeister gehört und der eben
auch über öffnung schritte nachdenken
will gute ist jetzt nicht in ihrer
partei trotzdem hat er ja sozusagen den
gleichen zumindest geografischen
background er sagt man müsse das tun
zumindest solange die zahlen auf den
stationen stabil bleiben haben sie da
einwände gegen
was er sagt ist ja man muss die lage
ganz genau beobachten und gemäß der lage
agieren und da haben wir ja überhaupt
keinen dissenz und während
glücklicherweise tatsächlich dadurch
dass wir in bremen so eine erfreulich
hohe impfquote haben eine entkopplung
von infektionszahlen inzidenz und
krankenhausaufenthalten und insbesondere
zum glück nicht so viele intensiv
medizinisch notwendige behandlungen bei
menschen die omikron oder corona
infiziert sind aber es bleibt dabei das
infektionsgeschehen ist aktuell so
dynamisch und die zahlen steigen und
auch der druck auf die krankenhäuser
wird noch zunehmend wir sind noch nicht
am pik angekommen das heißt wenn wir
jetzt zu früh lockern würden oder auch
zu früh das signal setzen würden stünde
kurz bevor
dann wäre das unlauter weil es ist jetzt
so dass wir erst noch mal eben bei den
beschränkungen bei der hygiene
beschränkungen bei den infektionsschutz
maßnahmen die den ja unser aller
gesundheit bleiben müssen um das
geschehen nicht unnötig anzuheizen das
ist ja das entscheidende weil wenn wir
jetzt zu früh lockern würden dann würden
wir eben riskieren dass die zahlen sehr
sehr stark ansteigen dass der druck
nicht nur auf die krankenhäuser sondern
auch auf die kritische infrastruktur
sehr sehr stark zunehmen würde und dann
müsste man wieder eine vollbremsung
machen und das ist wirklich
kontraproduktiv
hologic wollen sie direkt darauf
entgegne ich
glaube es ist vieles richtig an dem was
die kollegin sagt und trotzdem brauchen
wir perspektiven es geht um anpassen und
aufpassen und ich denke es schon wichtig
dass wir jetzt auch die chance nutzen zu
zeigen wo können wir hingehen unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen das erwarten
die menschen auch glaube ich jetzt
omikron ist anders als delta bietet uns
mehr optionen wir sehen das jahr an der
hospitalisierung ein stück weit an der
entkopplung das heißt wir müssen jetzt
weiter für das impfen werden deshalb
nach wie vor für ein zentrales element
die booster impfungen aber wir müssen
die menschen auch zeigen unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen ist es auch
möglich wieder ein stück weiter in die
normalität zu gehen ich halte auch
nichts von einem freedom day oder sowas
wie schon mal gefordert worden ist es
wird nicht an einem bestimmten tag des
virus vorbei sein aber ich glaube wir
müssen öffnungs schritte aufzeigen wo
wir hinkommen wenn wir uns jetzt weiter
an die regeln halten und nichts anderes
hat auch der ministerpräsident deutlich
gemacht ja ich lese gerne noch mal eine
frage an sie beide vor vielleicht fangen
sie an herold at fabian fuchs fragt uns
über youtube wenn die zahlen immer
stärker in die höhe schnellen und
parallel dazu die schweren verläufe und
die todeszahlen abnehmen sollte das
nicht ein indiz dafür sein dass wir uns
zunehmend in richtung herdenimmunität
bewegen was würden sie sagen
ich glaube das thema herdenimmunität
erreichen wir so schnell aus meiner
sicht nicht die frage der
grundimmunisierung ist eher eine frage
und deswegen diskutieren wir ja im
moment auch über ein der allgemeine
impfpflicht aber je mehr wir eine
entkopplung der neuinfektionen von den
krankenhaus bewegungen wahrnehmen unter
der rücksicht auf das natürlich das
personal weiter da ist desto mehr können
wir überkapazitäten reden über die frage
zweig plus oder zweig oder auch 3g
deswegen glaube ich die spielräume die
sich uns dann eröffnen
dankeschön vielleicht noch eine user
frage auch an die kolleginnen leon dubai
fragt uns über youtube hätte eine fragen
und zwar ob es bezüglich einer omikron
delta misch variante schon szenarien
gibt wie man damit umgehen würde also
was man aus den jahren gelernt hat ob
man nochmal einen lock down anstreben
würde ja da ist die medizinerin
sozusagen gefragt wir haben ja
tatsächlich die situation dass wir
sowohl noch steigende delta zahlen haben
als auch steigende und zwar dramatisch
steigende omikron zahlen es gibt
hinweise darauf dass wir auch innerhalb
der omicron variante jetzt noch eine
zweite zusätzliche omikron variante
quasi einen kleinen bruder omikron
beobachten können der möglicherweise
dominant werden wird wir wissen noch
nicht ganz genau ob der nicht sogar
infektiöser ist als die aktuell noch
wirkende omikron variante so dass es
notwendig ist
darauf rücksicht zu nehmen dass die
zahlen eben noch steigen niemand will
einen weiteren lockdown das ist ja das
was der user fragt sondern wir müssen
jetzt vernünftig sein und kurs halten
damit wir eben nicht in eine stärkere
kontakt beschränkung gehen müssen als
wir jetzt haben und insbesondere auch
die schulen auf offenhalten können das
ist für mich ein ganz entscheidendes
argument dafür dass wir nicht jetzt zu
früh in richtung lockerung gehen ja das
thema schule werden wir später noch
behandeln wenn wir zeitlich noch
dazukommen das würde ich jetzt gerade
noch mal außen vor lassen herr holczer
ich wollte ihnen gerade noch mal ein
paar zahlen zeigen hier bei uns auf
unsere app ich gucke gerade genau dass
diese findet zdf heute.de ist eine karte
deutschlands und bayern ist da hoch
prominent vertreten muss man sagen die
instanz zahlen angeht es gibt nämlich in
bayern unter anderem in starnberg aber
auch in dachau gleich zwei landkreise
die zur spitze gehören in deutschland
was die instanzen angeht 2500 und mehr
tja und anders als in bremen haben wir
für einen beitrag gehört sind auch nur
knapp 73 prozent der menschen dort
geimpft also werden sie nicht gerade in
bayern da besser beraten zu sagen okay
wir warten lieber noch ein bisschen
also wir haben ja sehr früh strengen
maßnahmen getroffen noch unter der delta
variante zum beispiel ab 23 11 bars
clubs diskotheken schankwirtschaften
geschlossen eine sperrstunde eingeführt
kapazität sehr eng begrenzt zweig plus
in vielen bereichen wir sind ja da sehr
stringent vorgegangen deswegen glaube
ich können wir jetzt auch ein stückweit
anpassen und diese frage des
stellenwerts der inzidenz als
seismograph die hat sich natürlich
tatsächlich etwas verändert gott sei
dank im bereich und in der im verhältnis
hospitalisierung genau die
hospitalisierung ist natürlich noch ein
anderes thema kommen wir gleich auch
noch mal zu vorher noch eine
expertenmeinung auch zu diesem thema
also vielleicht vorne auch noch mal
vorweg gesagt die bundesregierung hat
heute auch noch mal durch ihren sprecher
steffen hebestreit deutlich gemacht dass
sie lockerungen zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt für verfrüht hält eine stimme
aus der wissenschaft die diese haltung
unterstützt ist die von thorsten leer
professor für klinische pharmazie an der
universität des saarlands für hört mal
rein
lockerungen werden eigentlich jetzt der
falsche weg muss man sagen weil die die
krankenhaus belegung steigen an wir sind
jetzt wieder der musik die kehrtwende
eingelegt in den intensivstationen wie
auch auf der normalstation schon jetzt
zu lockern wäre wirklich fatal und genau
das falsche was wir bei der jedem stücke
und auch bei der aktuellen
impfbereitschaft endlich machen können
wir würden das am ende des tages bitter
bereuen und diese durchseuchung geht
natürlich auch mit einer menge lankowitz
fälle einher und wir wissen auch wie die
langzeitfolgen des satz 2 wir uns
einfach noch viel zu wenig
wir wissen noch viel zu wenig sagte er
herr holetschek da habe ich jetzt das
gefühl diesen fachmann müssten sie jetzt
noch von lockerungen überzeugen dass das
jetzt der richtige zeitpunkt schon ist
wissen sie wir sprechen ja nicht von
unmittelbaren lockerungen morgen sondern
wir sprechen von einer perspektive und
ich glaube das ist schon wichtig dass
wir den menschen auch perspektiven
aufzeigen wenn wir für das impfen werden
über eine impfpflicht sprechen dann
müssen wir auch deutlich machen wie
kommen wir dann raus aus dieser
pandemien natürlich müssen wir die lage
immer wieder konsequent einsetzen das
tun wir auch in bayern mit einem
stringenten monitoring durch unser
landesamt für gesundheit und trotzdem
glaube ich müssen wir darüber nachdenken
wenn sich das system so weiter schreibt
wie jetzt was können wir denn dann an
möglichkeiten wieder eröffnen das lässt
sich nachvollziehen frau
kappa konter was ist in ihrer haltung zu
diesem punkt ja den ersten schritt vor
dem zweiten tun also genau wie der
kollege eben gesagt hat wir haben
tatsächlich noch beträchtliche
impflücken in deutschland wir liegen mit
unserer impfquote gerade mal im
mittelfeld im europäischen mittelfeld
und wenn wir eine perspektive haben
wollen von mehr begegnungsmöglichkeiten
von lockerungen dann können wir das nur
tun wenn wir eine deutlich höhere
impfquote erreichen wir haben im moment
eine impfquote die liegt bei etwa
bundesweit 75 prozent das heißt wir
haben
erhebliche gruppen die noch nicht
geimpft sind und wir haben eben auch
gruppen von menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen können und das sind kinder
das sind zum teil chronisch kranke das
sind menschen mit bestimmten
behinderungen und auch die müssen wir ja
schützen das heißt wenn wir jetzt viel
zu früh und aus meiner sicht eben
deutlich zu früh lockerungen auch nur in
den raum stellen dann machen wir einen
fehler wir müssen sehen dass wir die
impfquote hochkriegen dass wir die
impfkampagne ankurbeln und das war was
die erstimpfungen anbelangt aber auch
insbesondere was das boostern anbelangt
und wenn wir das erreicht haben werden
und wir sehen wie sich die omikron welle
verhält wenn wir den peak wirklich
erreicht haben werden den haben wir noch
nicht erreicht wenn es wirklich wieder
nachlassen wird die infektionszahlen
dann ist der zeitpunkt dass wir auch
über lockerung nachdenken sollten aber
erst dann also da geht es ihnen auch
einfach um die frage sozusagen das
zeichens auch der symbolik wann spricht
man darüber wann ist sozusagen es
angezeigt auch diese diskussion zu
führen und für sie ist das noch zu früh
habe ich verstanden also auch um die
also gar nicht nur symbolik schon auch
welches signal wir senden aber auch um
das faktische und wenn wir jetzt zu früh
diese lockerungsmaßnahmen auch nur
vorbereiten und dann gibt es ja einen
gewissen druck die auch umzusetzen dann
gefährden wir eben einerseits die
gesundheit von menschen akut und wir
gefährden eben auch die entwicklung dass
die pandemie womöglich länger dauert als
sie dauern muss wenn wir jetzt noch
weiter kurs halten
wolle checke ich
sehe dass tatsächlich etwas anders ich
glaube jetzt kurs halten ist schon
richtig und das haben wir auch in bayern
in dieser pandemie immer gemacht
vorsichtig zu sein hinzuschauen das ist
schon wichtig aber auch durchaus jetzt
zu sehen wir haben es mit einer neuen
variante zu tun omikron ist nicht delta
und ich denke wir müssen den menschen
ein stück weit planbarkeit auch geben
ihnen natürlich sagen wenn sich ändert
müssen wir auch wieder nach steuern aber
mal wirklich eine perspektive auf zu
machen die leute sind müde die leute
wollen raus aus der pandemie und auch
ein zeichen der zuversicht zu geben wenn
bestimmte parameter stimmen dass wir
dann auch etwas mehr tun können das
halte ich für richtig immer unter dem
motto auch dass wir nach wie vor
aufpassen und nichts überstürzen aber
die sie zuversicht auch mal deutlich zu
machen die halte ich im moment für sehr
notwendig im hologic wenn sie erst mal
konkret machen würden welche lockerungen
und in welchen bereichen könnten sie
sich das denn vorstellen
das ist ein thema das wir im detail dann
besprechen müssen das geht sicherlich
auch um die frage wo sind die
kapazitäten zu erhöhen könnten wir von
2g plus wieder auf andere parameter mit
übergehen also da gibt es ja vielfältige
möglichkeiten die auch wichtig sind und
die richtig sind ich will übrigens auch
noch mal sagen die schule zu halten ist
für mich auch ein ganz wichtiger und
entscheidender punkt ja wie gesagt
schule machen wir gleich noch wir hören
vorher noch eine weitere fachmeinung
nämlich die von professor stefan kluge
er ist leiter der intensivmedizin an der
uniklinik hamburg eppendorf auch er hat
sich zu der frage geäußert ist das jetzt
der richtige zeitpunkt für die debatte
öffnen bzw lockerungen
wir können wirklich sagen und das
natürlich etwas beruhigend das zeigen
die ganzen daten aus den ländern die vor
uns sehr viel mit omikron zu tun hatten
aber auch hier ist die daten hier aus
hamburg aus bremen und aus berlin dass
die verläufe nicht zu schwer sind gerade
bei den geimpften ist dass sie eine
milde infektion große sorge machen uns
die zahl macht uns weiterhin die zahl
der ungeimpften oder der patient mit
demut defizit wo endlich gut geklappt
hat aber generell ist omikron deutlich
milder als delta das sieht man auch an
der zahl der intensivpatienten also
können wir schon sehr froh sein wir
haben natürlich war einfach angst dass
die große masse an infektion uns an die
wand drückt wir haben ja leider auch
sehr sehr viele mitarbeiten die die
momentan ausfallen eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser dass das system kollabiert
erwarte ich jetzt mit omikron nicht wir
wissen natürlich nicht was theoretisch
noch auf uns zukommen könnte an einer
neuen variante
tja also er zumindest das erwartet jetzt
erst mal keine überlastung frau kaputt
gonther kann sie das so ein bisschen
beruhigen ja er hat ja was ganz
wichtiges gesagt der kollege hat nämlich
gesagt unterschieden zwischen den
verläufen bei den geimpften und den
verläufen bei den ungeimpften und das
können wir medizinisch und auch
gesundheitspolitisch natürlich
vollständig bestätigen dass die impfung
und insbesondere auch dann das boostern
tatsächlich weitestgehend schützt vor
einem schweren verlauf aber das gilt
eben nicht für die ungeimpften und
wir haben ja eben schon darüber
gesprochen wie groß die impflücken noch
ist und dass wir eben auch
beispielsweise kinder haben die sich
nicht impfen lassen können und für die
haben wir ja auch eine verantwortung und
das bedeutet wenn wir nicht die
impfquote signifikant nach oben bringen
dann werden wir wahrscheinlich noch
einen deutlichen anstieg auch der
hospitalisierung fälle unter omikron
haben und darum sage ich erst
ordentlich impfen viel mehr leute impfen
ostern und dann können wir darüber
nachdenken auch zu lockern und das wäre
dann auch gut und das bedeutet dann
natürlich auch im zeichen der zuversicht
in die zukunft und ich bin sehr für
zuversicht aber ich bin nicht dafür
menschen sand in die augen zu streuen
und etwas in aussicht zu stellen was
jetzt im moment eben noch fahrlässig
wäre ich lese gerade nochmal 2
kommentare vor die ursache hologic gerne
ich wollte bloß einmal kurz ein haken
wenn wir das immer als zentrales thema
sehen was ich auch für wichtig und
richtig halte und wir tun ja wirklich
viel niedrigschwellige angebote man kann
sich sozusagen im vorbeigehen impfen
lassen dann müssten wir doch jetzt die
allgemeine impfpflicht forcieren dann
müssten wir doch jetzt schauen dass wir
da weiterkommen nicht ein gesetz erst
wieder verschieben irgendwann im verlauf
des jahres wann sollen wir denn dann
über öffnungen reden wir werden ja jetzt
an einem punkt sein wo wir das impfen
nicht mehr so erhöhen können wir sehen
ja dass im ziel ist im moment versäumt
worden also wenn ich dann erst über
perspektiven reden darf wenn ich
genügend kämpft habt dann befürchte ich
70 desserts erweiterndes jahr hinein
klar damit ist die impfpflicht
angesprochen das gesetzgebungsverfahren
ist auf den weg vielleicht wollen sie da
direkt darauf reagieren
sprechen ziemlich ein
sehr gerne also ich bin tatsächlich auch
der auffassung dass wir eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 18 für die menschen die
sich impfen lassen können einführen
sollen wir haben ja letzte woche die
entsprechende orientierungs debatte im
deutschen bundestag gehabt da habe ich
auch in meinem redebeitrag mich sehr
klar für die allgemeine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen ich hoffe dass wir da auch
zügig jetzt zu einer einigung im
deutschen bundestag kommen und dass eine
hohe impfrate ist tatsächlich die
voraussetzung oder eine zentrale
voraussetzung dafür dass wir in richtung
lockerungen gehen ich bin sehr der
meinung dass wir natürlich auch solche
diskussionen wie jetzt führen können und
überlegen können was sind kriterien was
sind voraussetzungen für lockerungen ich
bin aber eben auch ganz klar der
auffassung dass wenn wir jetzt über
lockerungen so nachdächten dass wir sie
zügig umsetzen wollten dann wäre das
jetzt noch deutlich zu früh und das
heißt wir müssen jetzt mit dem impfen
erstmal im vorankommen und wir müssen
auch sehen man wirklich der peak der
mikrowelle erreicht ist darüber haben
wir ja vorhin schon gesprochen im moment
rechnen wir damit dass es etwa in zwei
wochen der fall sein wird es kann aber
sein durch diese neue omikron variante
die jetzt an tränkt dass es noch etwas
länger dauert bis wir den peak erreicht
haben und vorher können wir für den
gesundheitsschutz der menschen einfach
nicht locker ich lese gerade nochmal
zwei dankeschön 2 kommentare vor habe
viel über youtube politiker sollten
nicht nur auf virologen hören sondern
auf experten aus verschiedenen bereichen
und dann ganzheitlich die beste
entscheidung treffen es ist nicht
aufgabe des staates ist jede infektion
mit einer krankheit gegen die man sich
schützen kann zu verhindern dass seine
meinung oder ihre seien wohl pia maria
123 bei youtube schreibt uns mit einer
impfpflicht könnte man locker dann wäre
nämlich alle gegen schwere verläufe
geschützt warum wird das nicht zügig auf
den weg gebracht diese frage haben wir
gerade
diskutiert so dann hatten sie beide
schon das thema schule angesprochen auch
dazu würde ich gerne noch einen kurzen
beitrag zeigen denn das ist ja ein
weiterer viel diskutierter schauplatz
dieser pandemie eva schiller mit einem
beispiel aus baden württemberg
das ist derzeit der normale wahnsinn in
deutschen familien schnäppchen in die
nase test am frühstückstisch die bürger
aus freiburg haben vier kinder drei
davon warten erkältet in zimmer
quarantäne auf einen pcr-test was wie
genau wann gilt anne müller hat den
überblick verloren ich will einfach
erschöpft ich kann nicht mehr ich habe
in den letzten zwei jahren viel
eingesteckt mit den kindern und das
gefühl der ersten monate der korona
pandemie wo man das für alle gemacht hat
und die maßnahmen man nachvollziehbar
das habe ich heute nicht mehr in
freiburg ist die inzidenz bei kindern
und jugendlichen auf über 4.000
geschnellt bislang hat man hier an der
alfons reichwein grundschule auf pool
also gruppen tests gesetzt damit ist
jetzt schluss war fast jeder test
positiv war wir haben von 500 kindern
insgesamt die unsere schule besuchen
teilweise über 250 fehlende kinder
einmal auf warten auf testergebnisse
aber auch eben weil sie in isolation
sind wo die kontrolle verloren scheint
wo die stiko noch immer keine allgemeine
impfempfehlung für kinder ausgesprochen
hat fragen sich viele eltern wie riskant
ist die schleichende durch solche bei
den infektionen von den kindern ist es
so dass die meisten kinder natürlich nur
eine milde akute infektionen haben oder
sogar symptomatisch sind aber ich glaube
im moment kann noch niemand wirklich
seriös ausschließen dass dieser effekt
nicht auch noch langzeitfolgen triggert
oder eben doch noch bleibende schäden
hinterlässt weil wir dieses virus
einfach noch nicht genug kennen die
bühlers haben weder zeit noch nerven
sich über solche fragen gedanken zu
machen augen zu und durch ist ihre
devise
also die situation an den schulen das
ist ein riesenthema über das könnte man
eine ganz eigene sendung noch mal machen
wir haben jetzt aber nur noch fünf
minuten herr holetschek das stichwort
ist gefallen schleichende durchseuchung
wie ist das in bayern also wenn dort
einen schüler erkrankt dann ist es ja so
dass dort dann auch nicht alle übrigen
schüler nach hause geschickt werden
sondern dass die ja im unterricht
verbleiben und das gesundheitsamt
kontaktiert dann also das wird ja dann
auch in der regel ein paar tage dauern
ich finde da so ein prozess dann auch
statt nehmen sie das in kauf wie es ihre
haltung dazu
also erstmal will ich noch mal
klarstellen dass für mich
präsenzunterricht auch deswegen wichtig
ist weil wir ja merken dass auch der
fehlende präsenzunterricht starken
einfluss auf die psyche auch der jungen
menschen hat das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen
das ist ja auch ein thema das man sich
stellen muss und ich glaube wir müssen
einfach die quarantäne klug aus steuern
wir haben die isolation bei dem der sich
angesteckt hat wir haben ein sehr
engmaschiges testsystem das geht gott
sei dank im moment noch in den grund-
und förderschulen pool testungen sonst
antigen schnelltests dreimal die woche
und von daher glaube ich kann man das
schon verantworten dass die die negativ
sind dann auch weiter in die schule
gehen können und dass man den unterricht
aufrechterhält und nur bei größeren
ausbruchsgeschehen dann tatsächlich
distanz unterricht wieder macht frau
katka sie hatten das für ihn
angesprochen sie wie gesagt sind auch
medizinerinnen und sie haben große sorge
dafür dass sich die situation
verschlechtern könnte was konkret
befürchten sie
canon auch schwerere verläufe bei
kindern und jugendlichen und das was im
beitrag eben angesprochen wurde die
langzeitfolgen also das was wir longo
witt nennen da gibt es ja auch hinweise
dass es eben auch kinder und jugendliche
treffen könnte in welchem ausmaß das es
im moment noch nicht bekannt so dass ich
auch aus ärztlicher sicht sehr davor
warnen würde von dieser vorstellung
auszugehen dass wenn sich erst mal alle
infiziert haben dann ist es gut sondern
im gegenteil ist es so dass wir eben
unsere kinder auch schützen müssen vor
infektionen und das bedeutet dass wir
natürlich in anderen bereichen jetzt
eben nicht zu früh lockern dürfen damit
wir unsere schulen in präsenz auf offen
halten können da bin ich ganz einer
meinung mit der politik dass das der
präsenzunterricht er ist einerseits
natürlich für den bildungs fortschritt
wichtig aber vor allem für die seelische
gesundheit kinder brauchen
begegnungsräume kinder müssen sich
untereinander sehen sie müssen sich auch
auf dem schulhof miteinander bewegen sie
müssen ihre freundinnen und freunde
treffen das heißt wir dürfen wir müssen
sorge dafür tragen dass die schule neben
offen bleiben können und darum müssen
wir die impfquote hochbringen und dürfen
nicht jetzt frühzeitig lockern noch
immer gibt es ja keine allgemeine stiko
empfehlung für die fünf- bis elfjährigen
für wie problematisch halten sie das
frau kaputt konter vielleicht zuerst
ich habe großes vertrauen zur stiko ich
finde es richtig dass mit der empfehlung
abgewartet wird bis wir eine klare
evidenz haben das heißt aber nicht dass
es nicht empfohlen wird kinder auch
zwischen fünf und zwölf zu impfen und
ich hoffe dass wir zügig ausreichend
evidenz haben werden damit die stiko
ihre empfehlungen auch entsprechend
anpassen kann herr hologic ihrer
einschätzung dazu
ich sehe das so ähnlich ich glaube
unsere kinder und jugendärzte sind da
ganz entscheidend ich weiß dass viele
schon impfen dass das beratungsgespräch
gesucht wird dass eltern sich
informieren und dann ist die impfung
möglich nach individueller beratung auch
in diesem bereich von daher denke ich
die stiko wird es tun und sonst die
kinder und jugendärzte center parat gut
dann letzte frage von unserem zuschauer
extrem büro iks über youtube guten abend
wird es eigentlich jemals wieder zu
einem volk owener leben zurück kommen
also wirklich ganz ohne verpflichtende
maßnahmen einfach so wie früher
vielleicht zunächst herr holetschek dazu
ich denke wir werden mit dem thema
kroner noch eine ganze zeit leben müssen
ob das die maske vielleicht ist oder
andere dinge aber wir werden ein hohes
maß an normalität wieder kriegen ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir dieses jahr ein
gutes stück schaffen frau kaputt konter
ihr schlusswort dazu ja wenn es uns
gelingt die pandemie in eine endemische
lage zu überführen also das virus
wirklich unter kontrolle zu bringen dann
wird sehr viel mehr normalität möglich
sein als das jetzt der fall ist und das
ist etwas wo wir uns glaube ich alle
gemeinsam drauf freuen dem schließe ich
mich gerne an ich danke ihnen beiden
ganz herzliche holetschek verkörpert
konter für dieses gespräch heute abend
dankeschön und ein herzliches dankeschön
natürlich auch wieder an unsere
community vielleicht noch kurz der
hinweis wir sind jetzt nicht mehr drauf
gekommen weil es einfach zeitlich nicht
mehr ging aber weil es angesprochen
wurde die hospitalisierung rate auch
dazu gibt es nützliche informationen bei
uns in der zettel erfreute
beziehungsweise auch eben auf dieser
seite hier können sie sich und ihr euch
gerne anschauen zum beispiel auch die
frage wieviel intensivbetten belegt sind
und welche zahlen da vor allem relevant
sind was es da zu beachten gibt also wie
gesagt auch ganz interessante
hintergrundinformationen dazu ok also
das war es von uns für heute abend
vielen dank fürs mitmachen für die
fragen konnte nicht ganz so viele dran
nehmen weil es eine sehr intensive
diskussion ja und sie auch nicht so viel
zeit hatten trotzdem vielen dank fürs
mitmachen euch einen schönen abend und
bis zum nächsten mal